[Applause]
hi CNN I know I'm dressed a little
strange but we were doing a sketch at
the end of our show you'll have to watch
it okay we have psychotherapist and
best-selling author Astaire Perales over
here we have Brown University Professor
who hosts the Glenn Show podcast Glenn
Lowry and we have the co-host of the
Foreign Affairs podcast American
proceeds Daniel Dustin
okay
uh what does the paddle make of scotuses
that's a Supreme Court ruling today
preserving access to birth control pills
yes that happened just before we went on
the air so that's the birth control pill
that that one judge in Texas I don't
know how that works I don't think I ever
will said okay I'm a judge in Texas the
whole country can't have birth control
pills
and I went to the Supreme Court and I
guess they threw it back to the lower
court I understand Clarence Thomas and
Alito
dissented
okay and said no no birth controls for
you what are your thoughts
well they made the right call
so Clarence Thomas made the wrong call
I'd have to say so in this case I'm I
I'm not privy to the opinions but
um I think a single judge overruling
National regulation in that way is not
the way you want to run a railroad
therapist on the pill that people take
to not have a baby I think it is
problematic to bring politics into a
conversation that should happen between
a woman and her physician of which
politicians know nothing about
that
all right for that answer you've earned
a bonus question
is there such a thing as a soul mate
so the interesting thing about soulmate
is that for all of history it meant God
the one and only today people will not
even sillier
go ahead some people that had a great
meaning but to turn our partner into a
soul mate to demand from our partner the
very things that we used to expect from
religion Transcendence meaning ecstasy
wholeness that is a whole new order that
has never been part of what committed to
our marriage committed relationships or
marriage ever was about
interesting boys boys makes a lot of
sense to me yeah
[Applause]
okay uh should we consider the SpaceX
rocket launch a success or a failure
what does it say about the state of
American innovation
I I think it's a success the fact that
it failed is part of the process the
fact that there was
nobody on board
yeah I mean you got to break some
Rockets to make an omelet
[Applause]
the first
I mean to me if we're trying to get
space travel why are we relying solely
on private corporations to do so uh I
think
historically speaking the nation this
nation has made its greatest
advancements in in technology when we
pooled resources together and there's
some form of central planning uh I think
this is something that we truly decide
democratically that we want and that's
how we should do it should we want it I
mean I don't see the reason necessarily
I don't either I mean I'm a musk fan
generally although he sometimes makes it
hard
big time yeah it's a private company if
they can't make a go of it they'll go
bankrupt if they can make a go of it and
make money from it then they'll make
money from it I mean you know
yeah I I just I don't I mean he's being
a guest on our show next week by the way
Elon yeah I'm very excited
um and I want to talk to him I've never
been on that page of why we should go to
Mars I mean however bad we ruin the
Earth it cannot be worse than a place
that has no air is 200 degrees below
zero
and a long way away and has six-month
dust storms and you have to live
underground and there's radiation the
ambition of wanting to do something as
audacious and remarkable is that an
expression of the human Spirit why
shouldn't we celebrate that from from
another perspective though you might see
it as a rejection of humanity if even
I'm no big fan of robber barons but at
least they would do things like pay for
operas pay for museums it seems like
this generation of oligarchs just wants
to escape Earth or live forever which I
think is a pretty Grim uh a critical
take on well I mean he he would say he
wants to escape Earth for a very good
reason that is altruistic that because
he thinks this planet is probably going
to be I can't say the word but rat
screwed uh
CNN I clean it up you see
um and we need this other planet to go
to but I feel like if we if it gets that
bad on Earth I I mean yeah I think it's
done then right but one thing I do agree
with Elon on is I hope we'll talk about
it next week also is uh AI being a
threat I mean he in a thousand
scientists and important people signed a
letter a couple of weeks ago that said
we should put a pause on AI and this
week I see there's a collaboration
between Drake and the weekend that is
not real
AI did it and it looks like you can put
the complete music business out of
business
because you don't need them anymore
so anyone who thinks I think that this
AI thing isn't moving way too fast for
us to deal with
I I think is kidding themselves and I
think he's right we should
put a pause on it
but in this situation who is the we who
would be able to make that determination
I feel like you'd have to get something
you were for the government all night no
that's what I'm saying yeah
don't want the government to get
involved there's a government government
yeah no I think I don't know what else
is going to happen I joke about it in
class I tell my students I know you're
writing your papers with chat GPT guess
what I'm grading them with jets
that's hysterical okay is the future of
democracy truly at stake in the U.S as
some content is there really an emerging
fascist movement well yeah
don't you watch the news come on you're
watching CNN yes there is but
no
foreign
I would disagree about identifying it
specifically as fascist even though
there is a far-right authoritarian
movement I don't think it meaningfully
mirrors the fascist movements of Italy
or Germany in the 20s and the 30s and I
don't think it's a particularly
mobilizing thing to do but I I
appreciate the tenor of the question and
I agree with it I mean fascism was
fascism yeah I mean we shouldn't throw
words around casually exactly
democracy people do throw that word
around very casually and there's no and
there's never any like specific
definition of it that I know of I'm
sorry go ahead no I think that if you're
going to go back to compared Italy
Germany they were it took one year for
it to go from an authoritarian situation
to a more fascistic situation and you
know it when you start to experience a
society in which there is a constant
polarization no complex issues can
actually hold their their polarities and
it becomes an either or you or me right
or wrong black and white that system of
culture reads this
great sister okay what does the panel
think of the video of The Dalai Lama
asking a young boy to suck his tongue
let me ask the sex expert about that I
mean I I was surprised that more
criticism didn't come the Dolly's way or
the longest way
whatever it was asking imagine if the
pope did that what if the pope said suck
my tongue kid
I mean we'd immediately be saying well
this guy has been in this pedophilia
situation that the Church of course has
paid billions of dollars because they
were and he just forgot he wasn't inside
anymore and and that's how bad it is he
said it in public I mean what do you
make of that the Dalai Lama saying that
I don't make I listen
I listen I try to look at situations in
context I keep my mouth shut and don't
just jump and with judgment and suck my
tongue kid you know yeah I I judge that
I'm I'm judging that idea what starts
before you have no idea before what what
situation is it okay for a strange 80
year old man say to a six-year-old suck
my tongue no no no but I don't know I
don't I you ask me all I can say is I
will not speak out on situations like
this none of them before I have an idea
of what happened here what happened
there I've seen enough look I'd work
with describe what happened here that
would make this okay like you're saying
something I don't know could have led up
to the tone comment and that's that's
not the point the point is that sounds
like your point no I think that
before you jump just to me before I jump
I take another couple of minutes to get
a bigger sense of what else is going on
here
is there any cultural yes that's of
course what I'm thinking do we know what
it means and it was it sexual was it I
mean we don't know that is the question
I have but I don't
what's the cultural context here that we
are quick to jump on it's ridiculous
like we wouldn't have heard of that by
now oh yes in Buddhism they suck the
kids tongues
it's crazy I'll throw it back to you CNN
[Applause]